right good morning everyone and welcome
to the town hall biniford and those
people joining us on YouTube for the
July plans committee there is no planned
fire drill set this morning so should
the alarm go off please leave the
building the way that you came up and
please do not use the lift
I would like to ask the committee
members to introduce themselves by
saying in their name and the war that
they represent and likewise likewise can
the officers introduce themselves so
I'll start off with councilor hepple
I've just said your name sorry
thank you chair um councilor kit hepple
my ward is Milton and Tamar side
uh good morning everybody councilor
Peter Haynes Apple door Ward
okay
good morning my name is Peter Christie I
represent Biddeford North
oh good morning my name is Jane Whitaker
and I represent Northam and Orchard Hill
wards
good morning I'm Doug Smith representing
Greg Torrington
good morning Simon back to you Phil
Pennington monthly and Blackford
good morning
good morning Christopher Wheatley Chevy
entry
good morning Tom vanstone Democratic
services manager good morning Rose
Whitlock and I represent two rivers and
three Moors good morning I'm Helen Smith
planning manager
morning Chris evely development manager
thank you very much so moving on to the
agenda item number one apologists
apologies chair good odds at number two
to receive the minutes of the meeting
held on the 8th of June
thank you
all those in favor
abstentions
to extensions thank you very much
Argent number three Declarations of
Interest members with interest to
declare should refer to the agenda item
and describe the nature of their
interests when the item is being
considered 11 members of Devon County
Council and town and Parish councils who
have considered a plan and application
by virtue of their membership at that
Council hold a personal interest and our
Deeds who have considered the
application separately and the express
view of that council do not bind the
members concerned who consider the
application of fresh which may include
further information
odd number four agreements between Parts
one and two we have no part two today
five urgent matches I have none Helen
have you got any urgent matters yes
cancer Crystal
yeah I I know it's very unusual for a
counselor to bring up an urgent matter
but
um there is something which I think we
need to think about very quickly
um as you're all aware we've had The
Travelers in Biddeford uh last week
quite a few problems but
we don't have a traveler's site yet and
it what concerns me enormously is that
our local plan which we're now rewriting
fairly rapidly
can we see the inspector actually
accepting and ratifying that plan if for
the second time we don't have a traveler
site we really need to look at this
quickly now I've suggested a site I know
we've looked for a site for years and we
can't find one there is one site it's on
the link Road it's the abandoned lay by
outside of rounds where it's got toilets
electricity running water already there
it's in public ownership
I understand that torridge in North
Devon made a joint application to buy
that not long ago and Devon County
turned them down I think we need to go
back and say them we really do need this
because I can see the inspector turning
our local plan down because he said last
time if you read it we need to find one
quickly if you go the second time and we
haven't found one I suspect he would
just say well I'm sorry I can't pass it
yeah I mean I completely agree councilor
Christie and perhaps we will make a note
the planning manager will make a note of
that and we will follow that up
[Applause]
so item number six public participation
the order of speaking is a member of the
town or Parish Council two members of
the public against two members of the
public in support all of the above had
three minutes each and finally the world
member may speak but they are not
limited to three minutes I will read out
the names of those who have read it to
speak as and when we come to the
particular application
so moving on tonight's item number seven
the planning applications the first
planning application today is
application one through zero four eight
two twenty two
71 residential dwellings in winkley and
it's on pages 17 to 77 of your agenda
are there any decorations of Interest
now I will now ask the officer to give
his report thank you Chris
thank you madam chairman um
so this is an application for
residential development composing of 71
dwellings
it's a full application
um
and it's within the local plan
um boundaries as set up in my report
in terms of updates there are no updates
following the publication of my
committee report but I should probably
just apologize to members for the sheer
length of the report and the number of
constantly comments
I'm sure it's been a long read
um
this plan shows the site
so it's it's the north of winkley it's
right adjacent to the a road
it's near the community facilities
football pitch allotments Etc
um access funds down to the east
Court Castle schedule ancient Monument
which you'll see it's an important
consideration is to the southeast the
Town Center's Southwest it's in and then
there's a new residential estate
directly to the West
when Clearfield you can just see the
remnants of it in the top so the left of
that screen
next slide please
uh this is site location plan you can
see from the topography that it's
sloping site with high ground to the
South uh coming to lower ground
in the northwest corner
um again you can see Court Castle
scheduled Monument
to the South where it says skate park to
the sort of North East
um that's where the elements of public
open space are
um
and then you've got Kings Meadow estate
to the West
next slide
and this sets out the 10-year plan so
you can see there's three blocks of
um
housing so some shed ownership and
affordable housing and then open market
is detailed in Orange
next slide
and this is the materials plan it's
perhaps not very clear but in effect
it's along the site Frontage there's
slate moves as it goes back it's um
slate collared tiles to be agreed and
then there's a mixture of brick render
and Stone
um Bound in terms of boundary treatments
the existing hedgerows are being
retained surrounding the site and then
where uh dwelling houses would
um about onto public open spaces such as
roads highways Etc
generally there's Walling or softer
landscaping and then in behind there's
um sort of his standard forever Edge
fencing
the highway access comes in as you can
see from the a road and then travels up
in behind the Hedgerow so there's a sort
of a gap back from the a-road and then
there's
some public open space
between that as well next slide
this sets up the drainage plan
um so you can probably see in the north
there's attenuation Basin there's also a
pumping station so the final series will
go downhill and then pumped back to main
sewer
the attenuation system would then go to
existing Watercourse
next slide
this sets out the Landscaping so this is
sort of a hogging path around the
attenuation basing you can see tree
planting there quite a lot of the tree
planting which is proposed is suitable
for um how wet the site will be at that
point
to your left you can see the existing
group of TPA trees being retained next
slide
this covers the
um the east of the site again you've got
a new sort of way in behind the existing
hedge planted area you can see some
trees and back Gardens and some more
soft Landscaping to the fronts of
dwellings
next slide
there's a sort of over spool car park
there that's part of the
um
policy it requires that and that is
anticipated to serve the Town Center
again there's a Hogan path
um
which links through
um to there's like a road which leads
down around Court Castle scheduled
monument and that would also link into
the king's Meadow estate so in terms of
permeability it increases some
permeability and then there's a planted
area separating some existing Bungalows
with some hose bungalettes which you can
see
next slide
this this um just sets up where the
public open space is on site and whether
private space is
uh the bits in Orange as sort of um play
on the way equipment I suppose more of a
lap than uh anything else and I'll show
you what those are now next slide
so they're just sort of a smaller Timber
facilities so it's not really designed
in a way that
the idea being we didn't want to compete
with the play facilities opposite
um the the bulk of the contributions go
towards the play facilities opposite but
this just adds some interest to the open
space
as you walk there effectively so it's
just a lap
next slide
this sets out tree protection measures
so you can see the existing Hedgerow
down the north
east and west and the existing TPO trees
on site are all protected and again to
accompanying his plan there's various
documents
as I said on top of plan to rewrite
accordance with our method statement
next slide
a rattle through the houses
quite quickly this is a free bed house
it's number three Red House group
more fruit that houses
two bed houses and one bed Mason there
is
one bed Mason that's again the designs
are fairly
simplistic the the idea being
sort of rendered walls Gray colored
roofs some portraits to add interest and
more finer detailing the character of
winkley is I'll show you in a minute is
generally rendered balling slate roofs
there's not significant in terms of
character I'm talking about the
traditional character of the British
Center
so it's rendered wool rendered or
cobbles a bit of stone slate roofs
um
and then varying differences in
buildings so it's more sort of subtle
differences in the building which make
the character rather than sort of vast
changes to houses next slide
two beds next slide
pool bed
another four bed
two bed bungalow
um free bed
another free bed
and a full bed
three and two beds
I've got a free bed
and this is um this is the sort of
Street Scene elevation so this would be
the elevation which faces the a road
sort of design concept if you like is
um to have a higher density Frontage
which is more commensurate with the
historic core of winkley then as the
site plus Bungalows to the South you've
got Bungalows which would
um sort of abut those so it's retaining
that Bungalow character and as we go
back into the site you've got um
effectively more modern buildings as it
links onto the existing modern Kings
Meadow estate so that's the sort of the
concepts which was discussed with the
applicants and as you see in my report I
think it works quite well as the
entrance to the village in terms of
trying to replicate that historic core
along the front
slide
again to some artists Impressions next
um we're going to do a quick Loop of the
site in terms of photos so this is sort
of standing down the field looking
at Court Castle monument and you can see
existing Bungalow there
um just up behind the Hedgerow
it's like
again this is Tim Bungie next slide
here's the modern estate
sorry my mic wasn't on for those uh who
are hard of hearing or online
um
so next slide
um this is standing sort of South north
and mixing things up here north of in
the site looking South
um again that's Kings Meadow estate
looking up and you've got Bungalows that
existing Hedgerow you can see will be
retained
next slide
this is uh quite hard to explain
this is as you travel down from the
Airfield as a sort of left-hand turn it
takes you around the back way of winkley
I suppose so it's just to get a sort of
visual impact of where where I'm looking
at so you can see
well you can't really see but um if you
were standing there you'd be able to see
there's existing resi housing in front
and then the trees in the background are
sort of the scheduled Monument so
um
that's um just showing it from a
distance I don't think there'll be
significant impact from that view
next slide
this is on the other direction so this
is on the a road just before you turn
around the sharp right hand corner maybe
it's called beachley industrial estate
or something I can't really remember
um but so this is looking across Fields
towards the site you can't see it from
that location it's just before the
corner and then the next slide
so this is sort of further back towards
the industrial estate you can see the
church Inspire if you really squint in
the background and then in front of that
there's a sort of a green field you can
see some housing to your right so that's
the field in question
um
this
photo is a bit deceiving because it's
from Google so when you drive the
Hedgerow is much more prominent so you
don't can't really see unless you've got
a good car and looked which would
probably be a bad idea on a busier mode
next slide
this is just in front of the site so
this is
um the entrance of near where that TPO
tree is and then behind that tree is
Court Castle the site's on your right
the Greenfield in there
next slide
this is standing from under that TPO
tree which was prominent in the site
looking back towards the other group of
TPA trees you can see the difference in
levels
next slide
I've included some
Google screen grabs of winkley town
center appreciate they may not be the
most up-to-date
um but it's just showing the density of
winkley's historic core the building
materials Etc you can see it's very high
density
next slide
and again very high density generally
render or painted render with steak
weaves or thatch and chimney Stacks
being prominent which again is a feature
added along the site Frontage
next slide
um these are the material considerations
um
you see my report that I'm recommending
approval subject to conditions the
report was fairly balanced there is some
harm to the scheduled Monument
but in my professional opinion that harm
is outweighed by the benefits of the
scheme
um that's me done back over uh to you
um chair thank you
thank you very much Chris for that
report so we now go to our public
speaking this that has registered public
speaker is Angela Finley who is
representing weekly Parish Council
um but she has asked for the planning
manager read out her statements
on her behalf so I will now ask Adam to
read out the statement
and you are speaking on behalf of the
parish council as a whole yes
not here right
good morning
once again we Face the planning
committee to defend our village against
overdevelopment nearly 300 planned to
date and computer-aided pattern book
designed Estates which pay no homage to
our democratically endorsed neighborhood
plan
first I want to look at transport and
connectivity the aspirations of the
neighborhood plan and Village design
statement were to encourage design that
prioritizes people over vehicles
country to our neighborhood plan this
estate has been designed to prioritize
Vehicles this will in turn discourage
active travel which was enthusiastically
endorsed by Adrian Avery Community
engagement officer
this development ignores policy
ttm-2 on new development and traffic and
will significantly contribute to
additional traffic and exacerbate the
already serious problem of log jams at
the school gate at the start and the end
of the school day
the cycle route alongside the main road
is hazardous this should be re-routed
and have direct connectivity to the
Village
the car park should have a grass grid
finish or cobbles rather than tarmac
this would make potential damage from
bikes skateboards Etc less likely to
occur and produce a more natural surface
no account has been taken of the regular
speeding which takes place as evidenced
by our community speed Watch Team it's
unlikely that speeding Vehicles
traveling over the brow of the Hill
will have sufficient time to stop if a
vehicle is turning into the new
development
winkley the largest local Center in
torridge require our award-winning
planning officers and councilors to hold
landowners to higher standards of design
and environmental concerns to prepare
developments for future generations and
climate change for example the actual
policy that deals with the specifics of
this site
w-i-n-o2 States very clearly up to 55
dwellings
given the number of planning approvals
granted since the creation of the local
plan we think it is even more important
to stick to this figure winkley already
has two new developments which have have
not had time to bed in or any time to
assess their impact on our village and
its environment and livability
the local plan also requires a high
standard of design that reflects local
characteristics however the character
and layout of the proposed estate are in
complete isolation to the rest of the
village and its amenities thereby making
it a satellite of the main village this
development could be anywhere in the UK
with its computer-generated formulaic
design there has been no attempt to
absorb the site into the surrounding
Countryside or pay respect to the local
architecture render painted buildings
and thatch or protect the historic I
don't like to say this is your structure
of Court Castle with landscaping and
tree planting there's just one short
paragraph cancer look can I finish that
we we in winkley have labored long and
hard at our neighborhood plan but sadly
we remain unconvinced that Torrid has
adapted its procedures to use these as
leverage to inform and raise planning
standards indeed our neighborhood plan
is not even made available to would be
developed Birds weekly Parish Council
considered that this application should
be rejected on design over development
and impact grounds especially has
torrage have now met
housing land Supply targets Thank you
Grandma our next registered speaker is
Pauline Warner who's vegan is a member
of the public against the application if
you'd like to come down to the front
and put your microphone on
which is the green button
and you have three minutes
thank you chairman
um I think it's quite interesting that
winkley seems to have morphed in this
meeting from a village not even local
Center through to town and I feel in
some respects that reflects in what
we're considering today are the
objections I'm putting forward relate to
the overall concept and design of the
development on the site
as a community in the past we've
fundamentally disagreed with the
conclusions of the planning officers in
relation to this
we fill the layout and design is
simplistic and unimaginative it takes
little account of the design policies in
the neighborhood plan particularly
policies enb4 and env5 and the more
detailed advice in the village design
statement neither do the proposals fully
meet the requirements of proposed of
policy win02 in the local plan
um proposals for the site have not been
conceived to enhance this part of the
village an opportunity has been missed
to create a village street style of
development that links visually to the
historic core protects the setting of
Court Castle and offers better
neighborhood creation there's been
little attempt to respond to
Neighborhood plan policies that do not
support pattern book design require
layout and housing designed to support
biodiversity and require elements of
craftsmanship to be included on the site
good design begins with the basic layout
of the site issues arise with the
straight in and out nature of the road
layout designed to maximize the number
of dwellings with a typical estate
layout the retention of an additional
access on the north side of the site and
the location of blocks of development
for example the affordable housing and
what appears to be in electricity
substation are all issues that need to
be addressed affordable housing is still
clustered on the site particularly in
the north rather than Pepper potted
across the site and there's little
parking and bin storage Etc in this area
and this is likely to result in a poor
living environment
um policy wino2 of the local plan
requires Community Woodland with
potential for informal Leisure and play
um we now seem to have some Woodland a
large attenuation Pond and play
equipment along the boundary of the site
good linkage to the playing fields
really renders these small equipment
areas unnecessary whereas the community
Woodland offers opportunity for Woodland
play and a greater diversity of leisure
offer for the village
all these issues were raised with
developers when the scheme was first
presented to the parish although the
developer has changed the basic scheme
has not the village accepts that this
site has been allocated in the local
plan and will be developed I asked you
to wind up quickly please come into it
yeah the views of residents at the
public meeting with the original
developers were clear the design was
unacceptable The Village deserves better
and Torres District Council should have
the courage to refuse it on design
grounds thank you chairman
our next public speaker is Pauline
odulinski is a member of the public
speaking against I hope I pronounced
your name correctly
cute
so you have three minutes when you're
ready thank you thank you
I wish to present to you several
concerns not adequately addressed in The
Proposal first this site is adjacent to
the important historic Castle Court
National England has quoted they have a
strong reservations about the level of
harm the excessive number of houses 71
from the original 55 will have on the
Castle Court scheduled Monument NHL
e106226 historic England also States we
have concerns regarding the application
on Heritage grounds we consider the
issues and safeguards outlined in Our
advice need to be addressed for the
application to meet the requirements of
paragraphs 194 and 195 of the nppf and
in accordance with the north Devon and
torridge local plan 2018 dm07
biodiversity and sustainability homes
need to be required to be fitted with
sustainable energy facilities ground
Source heat pumps and solar panels This
is an environmental imperative at the
heart of both of the plan certainly your
plan the torrage carbon and
environmental and biodiversity plan 21
and the winkley neighborhood plan 22.
the NP neighborhood plan policy env7
also requires houses to have facilities
for charging points and publicly a
charging Point facility too none of
these seem to appear in the plan
Wildlife on environment currently plans
for the boundary Hedges need to provide
more protection for Birds Wildlife such
as Dormouse and reptiles known to be
present
the environmental report states that the
boundary trees now provide little bat
roosting protection by increasing the
number of houses the adverse lighting
will also have a significant impact on
wildlife and Boundary Hedges adjacent to
the existing homes need increasing to
provide proper protection for wildlife
and privacy for home owners additionally
close boarding planned across the site
inhibits Wildlife movement and is
contrary to the wildlife objections of
the neighborhood plan policy env1
there is a need to revert back to the
original planning for more trees there
is little account taken in the plans for
a coherent connection between the
existing houses and Facilities
Waste Management finally current plans
do not have a full Waste Management can
I ask you to wind up quickly please yep
providing an increase of storage for
waste the density of housings provides
proposes means there is inadequate
facilities finally what we are urging
you as the elected members with
stakeholder responsibility is to listen
please to the serious concerns and
ensure that this proposed increase in
number of houses does not proceed thank
you thank you very much
thank you an expertise speaker is a
representative from the agent wasn't him
planning and he's vegan in support of
the application
you have three minutes again
foreign
good morning councilors my name is Alban
Henson I'm a director of Waltzing and
planning and we're the planning agents
for the application and my client love
are also in the room today
um attending this committee and thanks
for giving me the opportunity to speak I
don't intend to take up too much of your
time but I would just like to address a
few points and pick up on some of the
comments just been made by the other
speakers
um by way of a little bit of background
our application was originally submitted
in June 2022 but prior to that
we had saw pre-application discussions
and advice from your officers
and that engagement and liaison with the
officers and and consultees has
continued throughout the post submission
consideration of the application all the
way through
and as a consequence of that there has
been a number of revisions and
amendments to the proposals
resulting from those discussions
and many of those are referred to in
your office's report
and those include fairly significant
amendments to the scheme layout and
designers from when it was originally
submitted
some of those amendments include quite a
significant reconsideration of the
design approach and the incorporation of
design features
directly to better reflect local
character and materials and the setting
of nearby ancient Monument
um
the Amendments included
significantly more landscaping and
planting particularly trees I think as
you have been
shown on the presentation
and that planting is an integral part of
the scheme design and fully compliant
with the policy expectations
for a community Woodland as well
the Amendments have also
and the discussions have also moved
forward in agreement on the provision of
a pedestrian Crossing
providing enhanced and safer links with
the sports ground and in agreement with
the highways Authority they recognize
that the provision of that pedestrian
Crossing in itself would be a speed
reduction measure for that road
and you're also aware I'm sure that
there is a significant section 106
contribution package
with this that includes
um quite significant contributions to
sports and play space and all of those
are in addition
to the infrastructure that is provided
on site in accordance with this policy
including a new car park the community
Woodland as I've um as I've uh referred
so just turning to a couple of the
points made by the speakers and other
objections to the to the application
um
we've obviously just heard that the
parish council is concerned about that
this proposal is is is in some way back
and I asked you to wind up quickly
please okay
okay
um
as you're aware
and as the officer's report makes clear
a national policy expects decisions
um to support the efficient use of land
taken into account a number of
considerations
this application does that and I think
it's quite explicit within the offices
report
that that
is acceptable in in this case
if that's my three minutes I can assign
it to a stop there
78 seconds over sir oh sorry thank you
pardon thank you for your time
our last registered speaker is the world
member councilor Newton
chair members of the council thank you
I called this application in at the
outset
based on the density and layout issues
I have never questioned the principle of
development here this site has been
allocated for development for a long
time and is within the development
boundary of winkley and there is no
question about this site being suitable
for development
um
however
this site within the local plan
is subject to some very specific
requirements and directions
covered in the local plan namely policy
win zero two that you've heard mentioned
before and you have in your report
I can just stop stop by
reminding all of us
that the local plan is in effect
our direction to planners
so long as other
criteria are met and are in place
the plan that was drafted in 2017 after
a huge amount of detailed work in
consultation was independently inspected
and subsequently approved by majority
votes in both full councils North Devon
and ourselves in 2019 at that point
it became our Direction
to our planning staff
and apart from the period during which
the two planning authorities were unable
to demonstrate a five-year housing land
Supply
the policies contained in the plan
have and are material planning
considerations they are our approved
direction to our planning staff
so it's not surprising that I together
with many other elected councilors
become increasingly perplexed angry even
when our planning staff continue to try
to push the bounds beyond the direction
that we have given them
or what they can clearly identify and
know as being our intent the intent of
the elected councilors of this District
with that in mind and turning to this
application
the overarching policy in a local plan
covering winkley win
identified in 2017
a need for 60 houses in winkley over the
next 14 years
approximately 55 of which would be
located on this site
since then this committee has already
approved the building of 190 houses in
winkley
the first tranche of which is being
constructed on Townsend Hill as I speak
amongst others when also states that the
delivery will be through high quality
design and development that respects
local distinctiveness
as I said this site has its own
dedicated policy win 0-2 in the local
plan
and so is very specific and gives very
clear direction as to what is to happen
in Wind 02
the terminology is up to 55 dwellings
but this application is for 71 and the
previous before it was amended was the
72. a 29 increase over what full Council
authorized in the local plan
so why are Developers
and our planning staff to that extent
continually coming forward with
something that we have said we will not
approve
I am disappointed that and I know that
our planning staff push back on this
application which led to revision and
Chris has worked very hard and I accept
that with uh trying to to
progress the the the development of this
application
however to be honest despite what has
just been said at this table
the Amendments when they came forward
were
Superfluous they did not address the
main concerns in this application
and as such I have to say I'm
disappointed that planning officers are
recommending grants to you
if I was being disingenuous
I would ask the developers what part of
up to do you not understand
win zero two also requires that a
landscaped buffer zone be located
between the housing and the village car
park between the housing and the village
car park landscaped buffer zone
in order to provide protection for the
setting of Court Castle the scheduled
Monument
looking at the site plans and the
revised site plans this does not exist
not only does it not meet the
requirements specified in a local plan
but as you've heard historic England
continue to make a strong objection
they use the word strong reservation in
their terminology that is a strong
objection
lastly
I would bring your attention in the
office report to the housing mix
when I can find it
um
hopefully
perhaps over
excuse me for one minute
[Applause]
if you look at the housing mix
and I won't read what's in the report
you can see that however
the housing and economic needs
assessment the hedner which the local
plan uses as the basis for what the
target the mix should be and that's in
terms of house sizes Etc in any
development
is specified and is used as evidence in
the construction of the local plan
and therefore
hedner says that
the site should comprise of 15 one beds
35 two beds 35 three beds and fifteen
percent four beds
if you look in the report
we're nowhere near this
the allocation of of units here
two beds it's 11 short of what it should
be according to hedner
three beds it's five percent over and
four beds it's six percent over so
they're not even offering the the right
type of housing that we need
and finally I would endorse the comments
and I won't repeat them that have been
made about the layout for this site
it is boring Urban layout which does not
in any way complement the requirements
of this ancient Saxon Village with its
two historic monuments
um and I believe that this Council this
committee should push back on this and
say
these are the requirements this is our
local plan this is what we as full
councils have authorized and let's see a
plan that fits and complies with what we
have said because otherwise we might as
well throw the local plan out of the
window I haven't even mentioned a
neighborhood plan thank you
right that's the end of our registered
speakers now I will throw the matter
open for a debate who would like to
start off please
I will chair thank you very much
the problem I find with planning and
what we get at committee is that the
reports of offices for applications
we only see those
in a couple of weeks really before
we have to come to this committee
meeting and this is the same with this
if we could see more earlier
we could probably try and affect some
changes that we bring now and I will
bring now to this meeting because
uh I agree almost 100 with everything
that the public speakers have said
who've spoken against this scheme
um I think it's Dreadful
design it doesn't even come into it with
this scheme
um
so I'm going to be moving that we do
refuse this application
there's been as far as I could see again
this is a problem access to drawings on
the portal I couldn't get access to any
drawings and I don't know why we can't
but I was struggling yesterday to try
and find some of them we've seen Chris
put up this morning I'd love to have
been able to look at them beforehand so
that's something we need to address but
as far as I could see there's been no
consultation with the parish council or
the residents of Winkler regarding this
application
the applicants consider an outline
application they submitted to be
Consulting when I read through the
access design access statement that was
all they mentioned oh well we did put an
outline application back if you
instances
there's been no
that policy speaks about an investment
from the
Christy and I've
said
in the
issue
hasn't been
distinct
from the open
to mix the
intimate
the side
fans don't show
it's a
to the
therefore
quality
what is
the cat in it supposed to be a double
bedroom
and it's not clear
whether refuse Vehicles allow access to
all the dwellings because when I look on
the plant here
down at the bottom where the Bungalows
are it seems to stop short of
three of four
it's a lot narrower like it's just a car
driveway now our vehicles I know the
waste Vehicles will not reverse onto
that type of a surface so
is it going to mean that uh residents
are going to have to carry some of their
waste through that the end of the road
there I'm going to break off there
because of a few other points to make
but I'm going to end up chair by
recommending refusal for very good
planning reasons
yeah so bearing in mind if that's a firm
recommendation reviews or you will have
to put forward refusal reasons you've
got the misted do you want to say them
now so you in case you get a secondary
chair from the speakers I'd like to hear
what fellow committee members
oh thank you chair
um yeah I completely
um agree with what has been said by
residents of winkley and councilor
leather and this is a highly sensitive
Gateway site into winkley and we need to
um
it is up to us to actually provide a
sensitive design and layout for this for
it doesn't fit in with the winkly
doesn't
mention that
it as a
winkly
should take precedence
in the local plan and in our
consideration quite obviously local
people at winkley worked extremely hard
to put forward their policies
one Etc
uh design
to the Village
and we are
fulfilled
I concur
the design of the development
to us
Countryside
it's a
setting
and all
the
so
I would like to put
areas there's
alongside the main
wrong place
for the design
and spaces
got the housing in my view there should
be far more green infrastructure in the
design
National planning framework recommends
sets out that there should be tree-lined
streets I can't see much of that in the
development
um the treatment of the bike bicycle and
pedestrian access to winkley is not
clear in the plan how that would work
the housing balance account has been
mentioned that doesn't seem to comply
with what has been laid down in policy
um the affordable housing scattering
rather than just lumping it together
um
and the point about fencing and the
effect on biodiversity it's hard fencing
rather in soft access for for small
mammals hedgehogs Etc
so those are all points I suggest that
should be considered as well but are in
the main points in terms of design
um design of of the the developments and
how it fits in really and there's also
another point I gather that the waste
the waste strategy hasn't been submitted
yet I see in in the office's report
that's another thing we need to consider
thank you
uh thanks chair I
um likewise endorse what councilor
leather said and now counselor Haynes
I think
um the the overarching
policy here is is the Wingfield
neighborhood plan surely because
that is so specific in terms of this
development site it identifies it but it
does State up to 25 up to 55 dwellings
so
I can see no reason why it should go
above that figure and
um if if it were kept to 55 there is
adequate scope I would have thought to
incorporate that all-important landscape
buffer zone
between the development and Court Castle
so I for many reasons would endorse I'm
happy to be happy to Second the proposal
to refuse it
next
thank you
um I suspect the sticking point here for
our officers is going to be the fact
that this land is allocated in our local
plan that's going to be the main issue
isn't it when if they go to appeal which
they almost certainly will
when the local plan was voted on North
Devon and Torres councilors came
together
at Westwood ho there are a lot of
councils there only three of us voted
against the local plan
I was one of them and the reason I voted
against it was quite simply the sheer
number of houses that we were being
expected to allow to be built it was
imposed by central government we were
told I mean in Biddeford we had to have
4 000 extra houses absolutely
astonishing and I mentioned this because
and
three
overburdening winkly
our own
figures and what worries me is they
haven't changed much in terms of
sustainability
if you look at the figures and it's in
our own Ward profile 10 of the working
population are weekly travel more than
30 kilometers or 18 miles per day to get
to work
and another 22 percent travel up to 30
kilometers a day and you think
wait a minute these people are traveling
long distances and here we are talking
about a lot new houses are we going to
increase the travel within torrage it
goes against our climate emergency
declaration and everything else and we
need to start looking at this in quite
serious
ways but I go back to our support what's
already been said but I would like us to
look at the local plan again in terms of
we cannot just keep
allocating land and letting it be built
on willy-nilly
thank you chairman it would be very
difficult to disagree almost with
anything that's been said to date this
morning about this particular
application and but I really want to
focus on the neighborhood plan in
particular I understand where the
neighborhood plan sits alongside the
local plan but it's an enormous amount
of work for a community to undertake
it's really important
side the thinking of the community of
winkley and the neighborhood
thank you
um
set out
my opinion
but if you turn
I've set out why
it's acceptable
and
locally distinct
bungalows
okay cool
listen
ing
did why the
um why the design never the modern
estate is appropriate
design is quite an interesting one so
um and it's kind of it's almost a thread
that seems to run
take permeability that said
that is some
don't think
in terms of access
I don't really know what more you could
do it links with all of the surrounding
uh Estates which it could link with
um I can't just barge through someone's
garden and say we're going to have a
footpath through here to increase
permeability the actual size of the site
is quite small really so there's really
Limited in that regard as well
um
in terms of retaining existing boundary
treatments it retains all of the heteros
surrounding the site it's got a
landscaped area to the front
um
it has a new
it has a new car park which is
um both required by our policy and uh
the women can never plan
um it does create numerous benefits in
my opinion um I understand there's a lot
made on the up to 55
but that's not really how planning works
so what we have is a development
boundary
um development within that boundary is
acceptable
as long as
you can kind of show
that the density scale massing is
ETC is fine and also that's complying
with all the other elements of that
policy so my report details why it
complies of all the other elements of
the policy in particular it provides a
woodland which is acceptable it does
have a
attenuation pond in it but that would
have always been the case you can't an
attenuation upon needs to go in that
location it's the lowest point in the LA
in the land so that's attenuation point
it's been designed so it's shallower so
it can be used and it should be used as
part of that Woodland area it's got
paths surrounding it
um
uh again
if you're going to refuse it on the
basis of up to 55 you need to identify
what that harm is what what is the harm
of going over 55 where what issue is it
causing in terms of in terms of
infrastructure it's fine we know it's
fine
um the NHS haven't objected in terms of
doctors surgeries Etc the schools aren't
raising an issue highways are certainly
saying it's fine so in
can take it when I went to winkley on a
site visit you know the
saying oh do you want to come in for a
coffee
is that
in
School
housing
this is not just a case of saying
this is over 55 and it's not acceptable
it's within the development boundary
it's appropriately landscaped yes the
dance
it was up to me I think the density
you know
but
I think
that's which we don't really like it's
sort of intricate
and that
density which you've seen
so
is it on that basis
why
would my book can I ask for this
question then what is the national
guideline for um dwellings per acre then
and does that up to 71 does that fit
into that guideline
um I don't think there is a particular
guideline person I think that might be
slightly old in terms of
the pp and cheese which is before my
time and I'm very much an mppf planner
which doesn't set out those guidelines
what it does require you to do is
consider the scale density and massing
of the surrounding area okay which I
believe has been done we've
we've considered why it's more
appropriate to have a high density
scheme along the frontage again because
of character and Design
and it also encourages
so I'm trying to flip through papers
here but it effectively encourages you
to make efficient use of land so if we
can deliver more housing on this site
and it's approved it helps in delivering
tors council's housing delivery targets
it also helps in terms of we don't need
to build on Countryside elsewhere you
know if we get an extra 16 houses here
then we don't need an extra 16 houses in
the countryside location so that's all
it's looking at is the efficient and
effective use of land and it certainly
encourages that and certainly recognizes
the benefits of that as well thank you
for that any other yes captain
thank you for your explanation from
going from 51 to 70. odd
um
minded to go with other speakers that
have spoken before me here at the
meeting this morning
my question and I struggled because
winkley has really been
yeah we should look at every application
on its own merits as the basic principle
we've always been trained as committee
members
but the plan was put together in 2018 I
also there when coach Christie voted
against it I voted in favor it with the
gun against my head that if we didn't
vote in favor of it then the inspector
wouldn't pass it basically so we were in
a bit of a over the barrel situation
but what worries me on the plan is that
the situation is such that
it doesn't allow us the flexibility as
circumstances change in 2018 we had a
five year land Supply the inspector
passed it because we would have had a
five-year land Supply
and winkley has had a lot of houses
passed in its area
and how the effect on this Village
houses
per house
someone to be living in the
it's already there
get the
says we got
entity needs
but I
point of view
from
they've been
it's like
that point of view so
what
look at
is that a grown for voting against it
basically you're going to tell me no I
can see your consideration
um yeah long story short is no it's not
um the the local plan has Primacy so
you'd have to consider is this within
the development boundary
you
have had your fair share of housing
um
when the other applications were
considered they would have considered it
in the hull so they would have had to
consider are these are these extra 100
and whatever houses going to cause
significant impacts on infrastructure
and they would have had to consider that
that actually that
think about Professor Christie said
about the traveled work areas and all
the rest I mean that doesn't fit in with
our climate change situation when people
are traveling so many miles surely I
mean there is grounds to oppose it on
that point of view surely if you if
you've take these figures that are
coming through and weekly I mean
wherever you come come at it the closest
station is exit station I take it is it
and their connectivity to Exeter is
about the best yeah those Eggers and
humbly
I don't believe is there very good so
um well eggs was actually probably
closer than the train station in
barnstap to Barnstable from Billy so if
we're going on train stations alone it's
probably more sustainable than Billy
good but um that's part of the buy
really
um
I'm trying to make is is that it doesn't
fit with a
create so many
from from
um places of work effectively okay so
um
we can't control where people work so if
you drive right down the Link Road in
the morning we've seen many people
driving from
biddyford Barnstable for example 12
miles there's nothing we can do
this
it was allocated
for development so it must be presumed
that 55 houses
can be developed here and that's okay so
what you're then considering I suppose
is is an addition
yeah
and sustainable
what is the answers
I would have been
includes the
interesting employment
seconds
in responses to that
I'm sure the government would say
housing
um thank you Chad just um I come back to
this um the winkfield neighborhood plan
where it states in win 02 that quite
specific up to 55 dwellings and I I've
asked a question of Christian if I may
um surely that is ground enough to
refuse if if we are minded to vote for
refusal
will that be sufficient ground no so it
was technically it may say up to 55 the
inspector will look at in more of the
rounds so what is the harm of going over
55 what what's the issue here and so in
my report I actually think as benefits
of going over 55 it's not causing any
neighboring amenity impacts it's
appropriate in terms of its design
the layout's been described as boring
but um
which is a new one to me but when you
consider a layout what generally happens
is you have roads going across the
Contours of the land which is good
practice because ultimately it reduces
the amount of
um
hard Works effectively because if you go
the other way there's usually
significant hard Works in terms of
retaining walls Etc so they've used the
Contours of the land to deliver that
it's got a road which comes on the
inside of the existing Hedgerow so it
protects that existing Hedgerow which
then links into the car park
so once the layout may be boring it's
certainly functional so that's not an
issue so I think you need to if you if
you're going on the increase in numbers
you need to identify what the harm is
because that's certainly what an
inspector will look like
there is harm to the schedule attention
Monument so if you really wanted to
refuse it
that in my opinion would probably be the
only
refusal but
and that's
Mr Marvel
consider that harmed
and why there's
you have to
as
I will
if those figures are changing that may
actually change
I'm giving significant weight to that
public defender
okay thank you about just come
I understand
plans
yeah
so
neighborhood
he said you might as well just throw the
plan out the window
and come back
slightly
old sort of
plan the whole historic purpose is to
prevent the spread of development in the
countryside okay that that's kind of the
if you go to and look at the theoretical
and and if you went to Union and read
about planning rural planning Etc that's
that's the whole historic sort of
background to that so what we're aiming
to do is we draw a line around a plan
and we're we're aiming to prevent that
spread of development in the countryside
in this case by increasing the density
we're not spreading development in the
countryside we're just adding more homes
within the settlement boundary indeed in
winkley for example we could have near
the town Town Center or in another
location someone apply for plan of
permission to knock down two dwellings
and build four and that would be okay in
principle
um it's the same kind of thing we're not
we're not developing in the countryside
here it's all within the development
boundary and I've set out why I consider
the proposal is okay in that regard
can I just I'm sorry
um yeah it seems to me Chris has just
sort of I don't know presenting a
numbers game really more you know more
more houses means good but you're sort
of ignoring the quality to their house
about certainly
um you know the dense nature of this
Services there's less open space the
fuel
in the middle of the development it's
all around the side there's there's no
Greenery there's no shading
um taking you into account the future of
climate change and as we're seeing now
the dire necessity
to consider yeah
those ones we passed under the five-year
land Supply
seem to be added to the allocated ones
can we not play one off against the
other now is that not
possible because as far as I can see
winkley has met his quota already so why
are we allowing even more now well I
suppose it's the same old adage every
application on its own merits really but
I'm sure
Helen or cruiser come back on that point
um that's uh the simple answer yeah with
the um
with the risk of repeating myself the
simple answer is no we can't play them
off against each other it is within the
development plan
um the you know there's nothing I can do
I'm not saying it is a fair system and
I'm not saying I'm not playing a numbers
game
um
with regards to the green infrastructure
I should probably point out that in
terms of actual natural amenity Queen
space and parks and garden plays space
Etc it actually is policy compliant the
amount they've got on site is fine the
only thing that's missing is youth play
Space Outdoor Sports space and
allotments and the reason in behind
having those contributions
uh was because you've got a significant
Place based across the road which
they're linking to in terms of traffic
light system
if we try to get them on site equally I
could be criticized for why aren't you
why are you having two play spaces
within 500 yards of each other it makes
a lot more sense to take money have one
good area that's managed maintained Etc
um so I don't think there's an issue in
terms of contributions I don't think
reducing the numbers is going to result
in more Greenery on site it's just going
to result in a less dense development
which arguably
in my opinion would be less locally
distinctive Because the actual historic
nature of winkley as you as you've seen
from my photos in the presentation it's
very very high density
right well I think we've given this
application a very thorough discussion
and it's clear that committee members
have worked hard and done their homework
um it has been proposed by accounts a
leather and seconded by accounts
available to refuse the application
list of reviews
yeah I just
application
um
and heard um Chris them
foreign
obviously
developed
reason that there's less green
it's
look at the actual
I see a bit of grass
is at home
did you mean
Miss they did
if
I
green
presentable
the parish
this is
enable
the fact
supersede the local plant but it works
alongside it and it carries equal weight
it's not more weight but it carries
equal weight and I think not enough has
been mentioned about the demo plan both
in the report that we've read and and
the discussions this morning really so
what policy numbers are you going to
quote for reviews on them right
dm07 historic environment
st04
improving the quality of development
win 04
St and win O2
st15 conserving me conserving Heritage
assets
dmo4 design
non-compliance with the with hedner dm07
st17 the housing Mitch which makes which
doesn't comply with our headna
requirements which are pretty strong
when you read in the local plan what
they require there's no getting around
that saying oh well there's just a few
more of this if it you know it does not
comply with it
just ask the planning manager then are
they sufficient reasons enough for
refusal
thank thank you chair I think it would
be helpful Council leather to understand
yes we've got a list of policies and you
know it has been a really thorough
discussion with lots of points raised
but but how in what way are these these
policies is the proposal and conflict
with these policies and the the case
officer has responded in a lot of detail
around some of the points and you know
that the the concern of
yeah we're using for a few
to be
fine layout I think
refusal
em how
government is income
policy so
design and layout
then
everything
did reasons to turn
and I think the more
again the strong more like
it's important
then
I don't
for sale
housing and don't comply with head in
the requirement just a note that was
another
um regarding the Heritage our own
conservation officer says that their
Heritage assets
um the impact is considered to be less
than
substantialization that's not what
English Heritage said their opposed to
this scheme
you know I accept love you I think the
case officer would just like to
I I probably see it as
um you've listed some policies
um
I I probably see two reasons for refusal
coming from that so you've got a header
and housing mix that's st17 that's kind
of separate from the impacts on Heritage
and then he listed together
um some design and Heritage issues so
you could
are you saying here some of the long
lines of
um the number of houses on the site and
the design
um result in significant harm to
schedule monument and a reduction in
numbers pulling it back from the
schedule no the design did the design
aspect of the site is has it been said
by some of the objectives it's
the dense
itself
this
would
for and
this is for a review that's what I've
done chair and yes
yeah well you talked about the
neighborhood Platinum I've got env1
paragraph
basically add
the countryside
and the built up here
and holic
versus
I
setting in character of the
and any nearby
in the shed
Castle
two
right I think planning manager will come
back so if you give us firm guidance
yeah yeah so
my understanding is one refusal reason
which relates to housing mix and
affordable housing so that would be
policies st17 and st18
we then separately have
so quality DM dmo4 of the local plan has
a large range of sub points that deals
with a variety of elements of design and
what
has been expressed relates to the layout
of the development the architectural
treatment of the development as well so
the the design with reference to to
context
um
landscape which councilor Haynes has
just raised so policy dmo8a deals with
impact on landscape and this is an
allocated site within the development
boundary so
conflict with seo4 and dmo4 and
primarily what's been discussed is about
the look of the development the layout
and the density that landscape
consideration is more about a wider
context and Views and how it sits on the
edge of the settlement as well are you
saying you want both elements no because
this is a designated site I don't have
an effect on the countryside around
even if it's 55 houses that are properly
designed and laid out on the site with
more green space yeah you know they
don't have an effect in The Wider
Countryside
and the people of winkley accept that
because they've accepted this in their
neighborhood planners or developments
in cancer leather that you're putting
forward in your motion relates to the
design of the development in the context
of the site but with regard to the
adjoining sort of built form of winkly
as well so that would be
the
foray
s
the corresponding
they're from the
she's cited
office
phone
call
when
absolutely and that's what it's all
about at the end of the day just one one
final point if I could raise on on the
Heritage side of things so Chris's
report
um identifies I believe less than
substantial harm so there is then a duty
under the national planning policy
framework to assess that against
benefits of The Proposal so I think it
is important that the committee through
that reason for a few sort of articulate
that as well
um
are you saying that the the harm to the
heritage heritage asset
um outweighs the public benefits of The
Proposal
fit of this side as proposed what is the
problem let the case officer set that up
I mean in in in the winkley plan it
speaks about a proper screening at the
sets of an end of that development site
because of the Heritage asset there
there isn't any there's Bungalows down
then a couple of trees
yeah of course yeah
um so I in my report I've known to do a
great public benefit in particular
71 houses 30 of which will be affordable
which will contribute to the council's
housing need a pedestrian Crossing
linking the site and and existing public
footpath to The Wider public foot mouth
Network and winkley sports facilities
slash Hall
uh interpretation boards to raise
awareness of Court Castle and its
importance
a benefit to local economy and community
in respect of contributing
ability of winkley for example new
residents will support local businesses
Etc
increase
just to remind on the historic England
advice
um they do advise again of strong
reservations regarding the level of harm
even
pathetic
on the significant
core
English heritage
I just
oh
they're making their own destiny as it
were and to ignore that I think is a
it's just not right and surely that
alone is is a ground for refusal
em
um thank you Council Apple I I would say
just because someone's objected to a
scheme a bit local public or someone
from far away it does it doesn't and
never has been a ground for refusal that
is the contents of the objection which
is the important part and that context
would have to say why it was or was an
inequantive local policy indeed which is
someone supports a scheme doesn't mean
we should approve it
right one just just one last comment
then yeah I don't know where the council
wants to take on board
um policies sto3 in the local plan
relating to adapting to climate change
and strengthening resilience it seems to
me paragraphs G ensuring development is
a resilient to impacts of climate change
power RH ensuring risks and potential
climate change hazards are minimized and
paragraph I
um
strengthening resilience of biodiversity
facilitating migration Wildlife between
habitats relate to this particular
development and especially in the
context of what
um thank you Council Ames
um
personally I would recommend against
that so in terms of the fencing Etc we
could condition that there were mammal
holes Etc so that would cover that issue
um
in terms of
the impacts on
um in an area which
um is then going to cause furthest
flooding Downstream
um it would have electrical vehicle
charging points of as part of new
building regulations
um so I personally would
listen for refusal
em
you know quite strong and defendable so
up to it
right
before
I think
you're making if we could
use that
counts
entire
HD
go to
patients
you feel
defense would
and then
Distributing
the plate
apart
we can't
after reason and have that that
confirmed and in terms of the
corresponding neighborhood plan policies
do you do you have those Council leather
or do you want officers to
yeah I've not got those listed but
please add those in as well they've
correspond
s yeah
before we go on chat Just One Last Point
there's two questions actually what is a
hogget bath
you know a hogget path
what is a hogget path does anybody have
ever heard of it
you know sometimes you walk down
somewhere it looks like it's like a
colored Hearthstone membrane it's not
quite tarmac it's that it's a hard track
it's another type of hard surface that
isn't tarmac effectively and another is
a plea really because
education please when you list all the
trees on these sites don't put the Latin
names down just pop the names down we
all know them back well again more
homework to do accountants I love them
that you're in terms of the heritage
specs you are saying in terms of the
mppf test which
benefits
living
that's not
so just to clarify
um historic England's view is actually
they conclude that it's less than
substantial harm so there's there's
effectively free tests okay no harm
lessons substantial or significant
so historic England is saying there's
less than substantial harm it's on the
higher end of it okay so that's that's
effectively what they're saying
um
that that concerns on site Etc were that
um they had the developer hadn't done
enough information to prove that they'd
considered
all of
um
the scheme in terms of have they
provided the correct viewpoints Etc
um and was that then
I'm going to show more harm or less harm
but
either way which is sat on my but
there's not going to be no harm so
further Landscaping isn't going to
create no harm the very nature of having
55 houses next to the scheduled extra
Monument would mean that there'll always
be lessons of sexual harm and historic
England accept that what he's talking is
saying is it could be less of a less
than substantial harm in terms of being
on the higher end of less than
substantial harm by Landscaping trying
to pull back dwellings Etc
um
well the English language is a wonderful
tool the English language is brilliant
you can make everything
what about the sewage thing I mentioned
Jacob some can't be addressed eventually
right
sorry
and what might that Amendment be
ings
I would just check at that
it's ready for the octopus
so you want that you want that added to
the list of all other
objection reasons
foreign
thank you just
revise that probably
is of risk
um amendment in terms of does it add the
potential from reasonable behavior and
um is it defendable
um just but it's your choice
UMES we have got
several already policies for refusal and
you know to add perhaps not a very
robust one
as an amendment
I personally would not be happy with
either you want to go with the good
reasons that we've already quoted sto
form
foreign
um Council led the seconded by accounts
and I have all for
several reasons st17 St 18 dm04
and
so
councilor Haynes councilor Harper for
councilor leather or councilor lock for
councilor Pennington or councilor Smith
for councilor Wheatley or councilor
Whitaker
so that application has been misused
thanks very much
so I'll just wait for the weekly you're
more than welcome to say winkley but I'm
sure
foreign
this is an outline application for 17
dwellings with all matters
reserved except access and layout that
offers some two pence at the end
um
in terms of
updates I'll give you that at the end in
terms of my own opinion on James's
support
um if you go to the next slide
so this is the site you can see viden
Village to your left uh and whole survey
to your right and the site is outlined
in red the applicants remaining land is
outlined in blue next slide please
this is the hosavi development boundary
and the red arrow points site
next slide
um this stuff is monetary next slide
um this is the site layout so it comes
in off the arrow to the top
um there's an attenuation pond at the
bottom it's actually
a mixture of infiltration and
attenuation which is why there were some
delays in the in this one because Devon
County came back on that
um
is
um again that's that's the layout you
have to consider that and the access you
need to consider you've got a sort of a
cluster of two beds at the top coming
down to larger buildings the land drops
down
um there's some pedestrian linkages
through the site
next slide
this shows the drainage strategy so
again you've got um
it's like a created system which then
goes into an attenuation slash
infiltration pond
next slide
this shows the levels quite nicely
so the landslopes from High Ground to
the north to the low ground to the South
you're not considering design or scale
at this stage
or appearance
this just shows what will be removed
from the start and what will be retained
so there's a sort of existing head tray
which is labeled in blue
that be retained is as clearly shown on
that it it's proposing that the
existing trees removed and that the
Hedgerow along the front of the site is
cut down it says for ash dive at reasons
but
um
Landscaping is not being considered now
so that can be hopefully reconsidered at
a later date
next slide
this shows the hedge row along the front
which is used to be removed and the
um
the high wave is displays I should note
there is a mixture of planting in the
outro it's not just ash let's slide
shows looking the other way up towards
riding
let's slide
this is within the site sort of on the
on the higher ground I suppose looking
at the site entrance
next slide
this is looking back towards the the
blue land or Gap in its house and you
can see that Hedgerow screening the site
on from the highway
next slide
this is at the
um southwest corner uh these trees in
front of you will be removed and then
you've got the
um
the access Gateway in behind that next
slide
and that's looking up the side to the
higher ground
from the same location
um sort of looking Northeast I suppose
next slide
and then that's looking directly is from
the same point those trees again to be
removed
um next slide
this is from the southeast corner of the
site again show looking pretty much
directly at the access
um so the hetero and on top will be
removed and please be removed and then
the headshot sort of in the far
background we've attained and then
you've got the sloping land clearly
shown
next slide
this is in this South East looking up
towards South African City dwelling
house next slide
the attenuation basins
approximately in this area the opposite
of this hedge which you can see now
slide
uh this is the prince wood uh this is
the main main material considerations as
set out in James's report
um the only things I wanted to add which
can really see in a report again I got
this at a late stage
um
James is quite clearly set out why the
affordable housing is not acceptable in
terms of 10 year mix
it's probably also worth pointing out
that we have our own affordable housing
supplementary planning document
and that actually sets out the approach
to restricting the price of discount
open market dwellings so they're
offering a 20 discount
whereas on this site it should be
significantly more than that so we're
looking at 39 discount for two bed
property in order for it for it to
actually be considered affordable
dwelling
um otherwise it's just a discounted
dwelling in effect
um but also if it were me I'd probably
be either recommending a slight change
to loud to the north which you can't
consider now or the attention of that
Northern hetero I think that Northern
hedra is very important in order not to
present significant impacts to the
character of that site but James hasn't
mentioned that so
to introduce speed kids thank you thank
you very much and so I was ready to
speak is Brian Turner the agent who is
speaking in support
of the application
uh well good morning everyone uh thank
you for the opportunity to speak
I'm going to be as brief as I can I do
have a lot to say however
I'm trying
um with regard to the history of this
application it is one that's Laden with
delay and procrastination I regretfully
have to say this I've had a high regard
for torrage in my working relationship
with them has been productive and
Splendid over many years we have a
pre-app that started in February 22 that
became
unconcluded seven months later when an
officer left and some of the matters
which have been raised in the report
were actually tabled at that time for
conclusion in advance of a structured
application
validation has been
fraught in 23 but this was submitted at
the end of 22 an example of that would
be that the comprehensive planning
statement was sought to be broken down
into nine separate reports with no new
content just new front covers and cut up
and handed back in again three points
for submission were agree with
validation officer and they were
overruled by somebody and it became a
one-month process
the application went in in January
according to validation dates we had no
contact from anybody for three months
the duration of a major application and
then that culminated in a site visit
which was very positive for hasten to
add I would also add that what I've
heard about winkley today there seemed
to be no negatives to speak of
whatsoever regarding this scheme when
you compare winkley's assessment this
morning it's got a clean bill of health
one person has commented recently a
local person we believe a recent arrival
in the area but there has been no public
objection at all
the application I feel to an extent and
I apologize to a gent in the room who I
know and is part of that organization
Devon County took charge of this
application by their request for
information actually the excessive
requests that they took and sometimes
the timely the lack of timely
information requests in particular we
have a drainage strategy which has been
thrashed to death to building regulation
stage at outline planning stage and
actually the 200 scheme opposite the
outline scheme which has been approved
all of these matters this same objector
chose to allow that on a planning
condition if that one matter had not
taken place we wouldn't be here today
this would have been delegated done and
these houses would be a benefit to
holsworthy
I challenge to an extent The Five-Year
situation at the moment I believe it is
temporary pending and there are
variables that will come into play in
due course outside assessment
subsequently whether there are appeals
which may have a bearing on this in an
unto distant future and I believe we are
in a fragile situation with it in total
and actually the number is fragile in
its own right
also 421 the paragraph in towards his
own document regarding affordable homes
and the creation of numbers says the
consideration should include
intelligence and knowledge within the
planning office of of sites which are
under discussion and potentially going
to become available
I beg your pardon
this side of town is very important
there's a planning appeal via the high
court Crown versus witchhaven where
Justice Coulson said don't just consider
red felt tip pen lines look at
sustainability look at benefit and
balance that against harm here there is
no harm there are tremendous benefits
and this is part of a growing town in
the West
thank you for your time
thank you chair thank you for committee
um it seems to be coming in a regular
occurrence I was here at the last
meeting
um and much of that is coming about
because of the sudden information
of the five-year land Supply which I
have made several representations for
smt level about my concerns about that
it in terms of planning I I think some
things have been said about the local
plan today it was adopted in 2018 after
10 years of consideration
in 2019 when I become leader we had a
new jppc committee and immediately there
was concerns about the local plan about
what it was delivering and oddly enough
a lot of that came from North Devon who
was noticed who as recently and I'll
come to other reasons decided that we
wouldn't do a full review but we
actually voted as a full Council for a
full review of the local plan in 2020.
obviously covert intervened and the time
has gone on and now we have this
situation that North Devon would prefer
or have said they would prefer to have a
targeted partial review
when you get your agendas for full
Council tomorrow you will see that we
are not taking that approach as a
council we have decided there are issues
within this plan that we need to address
and we will be looking at a complete new
plan or
a plan that's more fit into what the
community wants that is what the terms
of reference will be and
oddly enough and it is oddly enough when
you look at what we're trying to do with
Devon Futures with North Devon I'll come
back to the actual application in a
minute with North Devon and torridge how
we're trying to drive the economy
forward North Devon have accepted that
the local plan could be a hold up to
that
and last week we had a meeting with our
MP where we discussed how we're going to
deliver
there's a huge opportunities once in a
lifetime to torridge again it was
discussed that the local plan isn't
could well be an obstruction so we're
going to go forward as a council having
got my usual lecturer out of the way I
just deal with this application I don't
do in details I do with what is right
and what the community wants
complete opposite to the last one this
is a development that is not objected to
it's also a development by a local
person businessman who is responsible
for regenerating the Ryden in which is
just up the road which has become a
place to eat and a place to visit and
also rescued the golf club from closure
with some of our councilors actually
play golf at so that is a major material
consideration to the growth of the area
that we are that the developer is
investing in the area this is not a
Building Company taking money away and
giving vast amounts of money to
shareholders this is a community
investment in terms of policy
the previous speaker spoke to the high
court case the ruled that you have to
give material consideration to
applications that are outside the
development line and if you read the
mppf it says there is a golden thread of
thought that we should be delivering
what is considered to be material
considerations that do affect
established local plans now this is
right next to holsworthy the interesting
thing is it's next door to a retirement
village which is high quality build so
high quality that the developer went
bankrupt first time because it was
costing them more to build the hoses
than they could sell them for because
there's obviously a 55-year age
restriction and that development will be
coming right down when it gets to Stage
six right down to the boundary of this
development
as you can see from the pictures of the
the applicant's lawn and garden
when he does things he does it properly
and that's my assessment I've been
living in the area area for 50 years and
this has been my ward for very nearly 20
years
so on the grounds that it does comply
with the mppf
that there is a golden thread of
material consideration that would a
lower development just outside the or
joining the boundary I think it said
which is what this does in effect and
also one of the benefits where you would
see where the cars were parked in the
lay-by
the retirement village
originally was supposed to provide a
footpath down there to the toe and it
was going to be after seven houses then
it was going to be after 11 hoses
and then an agency officer has agreed
that they can build it when they finish
the last house
so I will be looking that there will be
improvements there is already good
access from this site that's in the
issue into holdsworthy and actually
better access than the 200 homes are
going to be built on the other side of
the road
so I won't hold you up any longer it's
been a long morning
I have to say I've heard some stuff
that's um I will take away with me but
thank you Chad I hope in a good way
Council James
right there's no more public speakers so
I'll open up the debate who'd like to
start please
yes
just a couple of questions
um for clarity uh I see that there's
been a comment from pie with the Parish
Council on Pace
80.
is it in piworthy or Hosley town
why is there no comment from her I
assumed it was in holsworthy town
I'm looking at page 60 I see a comment
from from
oh 86 right thank you
well and just secondly
um on page 87 principal development
um it's uh second paragraph down in the
bill print within the development
boundary and somebody's
um parenthesis my
my uh emphasis who is the my
my would be James Jackson
of the report yeah okay thank you very
much
yeah I know that it's outside a
development boundary as a reason for
refusal
um I don't like to say the slippery
slope argument but if we've had other
applications like this where they've
been it's been argued that it's adjacent
to development or next to existing
development I mean it's it's actually
you know in policy terms in the open
Countryside and that's strengthened by
um holdsworthy's comments that um the 80
affordable housing is not really
affordable in the context of local rent
levels so in my mind that reinforces a
reason to refuse on the grounds that's
outside development boundary
um I also query The Pedestrian cycle
link whether there is one
and also I'm concerned about the loss of
mature trees on the site
rather nice there I understand they're
going to be filled
and there's also a comment about the
lack of waste a waste policy or strategy
which we had in the previous
application actually
so let my comments
can I just ask them is states that the
landscape visual impact study has not
been repaired in accordance with glv
183 has that been reasonablendid or is
it still as it stands
um that still as it stands but um James
does conclude that it's broadly
consistent with its own assessment so to
actually undertake a full Landscaping
visual impact assessment is quite some
piece of work so we wouldn't normally
request that if it's not really that
necessary so James looked at what's been
submitted is considered yeah that's
probably about right and then and then
gone with that to actually do a full
lvia you need sort of quite specialist
cameras for example so that the idea
being you can hold up that sheet at eye
level for example now and you can
understand what that impact is going to
be whereas
um he's saying in effect is
whilst it's not uh
in accordance with the guidance there's
no actual issue with that it wouldn't be
necessary to jump through more Hoops
yeah and also it does one other point I
don't know if you can get the slide up
at the site it's in the report it says
there's a third party dwelling within
the science I couldn't quite forget
where this third party
when it was
I I can only presume that he means the
applicant's dwelling which is in in blue
I'm going to look yeah but that wouldn't
be a third party to anyone no so just
looking over there is he going to shake
his head when I say there's no dwellings
in here yeah so it's just a site and
then the Africans dwelling is adjacent
to it there's no other bill for it and
where are the nearby industrial
buildings
um so there are yeah
so all I too was disappointed in the
affordable housing
um
Eric reception that the they went back
to the applicant and he wasn't willing
to change it so I was disappointed in
that
just a question when I look through this
I couldn't see any consultation with
Southwest water did we go to them it
goes back to what councilor leather said
earlier about our issues about uh sewage
control
Haynes was yours and certain proposal
for reviews the ones set out in the
office report yes it was right thank you
as far as we're aware there was no
consultation with Southwest water
undertaken
there's certainly been no comments
received so I can only presume we
haven't consulted
worrying uh given you know all the fuss
about
sewage spills and so on
surely I thought they were a statutory
Consulting
um I don't know the answer to your
question does it worry me not really if
we were to Grant plan permission they
would have an obligation to improve the
systems uh the the this
no no that's fine you know I I I as
someone that uses our seas and rivers
Etc I'm equally
um as frustrated as everyone else in the
working practices of
um
the company that I don't think we can
control that fire planning
the comments any other characters wish
to make any comments
yeah
following all that discussion I know
that um page 92
the foil water would be pumped to the
north and discharged to the existing
combined sewer
but new company station has shown I just
you know I mean there is no Clarity on
the issues you're raising here
again I don't think
is an issue because they would be
obliged to improve their infrastructure
but um again
I don't want to speak for selfless if
I'm not the consul team so they might
object but would be incredibly rare in
my experience that that would happen
thank you
yes guys
thank you chairman um just just a couple
of things our officers think that it
does not reflect identified local or
housing needs which I think is a bit sad
alongside the fact that the um the owner
though the developer was not prepared to
consider a proper um proposed affordable
housing provision even after he was
asked to reconsider yeah that was my
appointment I mean and then I add to the
fact that it is outside the development
boundary for the area and I understand
what councilor James is saying
um but you know I am very resistant to
to doing more
and I say harm in The Wider sense in the
open Countryside than has already been
done in the past few years when we
didn't have our five-year housing land
Supply and we couldn't do anything about
it thank you
thank you chair
um well it's out it's outline
application this with access really to
be determined and not really any of the
other things that would come forward in
a reserve matters application but
can I just ask would this be considered
to be development within the cartilage
of the dwelling that's there
rather than just in the countryside
okay I can come back so um
that's actually covered by
um the national planning policy
framework in particular it's covered in
a glossary page 71.
of previously developed land States land
which is or was occupied by permanent
structure including the cartilage of
development land
and any Associated surface instructure
this includes land that is or was last
occupied by agricultural forestry
buildings land that has been developed
for minerals extraction or waste
disposal for landfill where provision
for restoration has been made through
development management procedures land
in built-up areas such as residential
Parks Gardens recreational grounds and
allotments and land that was previously
developed but where that remains a
permanent structural fixed structure has
been blended into landscape so I mean
that's a bit of a mouthful but what it's
effectively saying is resident
development should be should not be
treated as previously developed land and
should be treated as
Greenfield effectively so if you're
considering any Garden it's previously
developed then you're opening the
floodgates to any Garden anywhere in the
district to be developed as a house in a
vet so that's not what we want and
that's not what the national planning
policy framework implies
Captain's abandoned him isn't it
on the scriptures open Countryside and
um you've dealt with that point thank
you right so there's no further comments
that has been proposed
recipes
all right
um the blind manager has just said that
Southwest water were consulted but they
did not respond
yes cut is another thank you
just to follow on from what the planning
officer just said then I'm looking on
page 19 of the mpbf at 71.
and it says wear an allowance is to be
made for windfall sites now would this
be classed as a windfall site
um as part of an anticipated Supply
there should be compelling evidence that
they will provide a reliable source of
supply
any alarms should be realistic having a
regard to the Strategic housing land
availability assessment historic
windfall delivery rates and expected
future Trends plans should consider the
case for setting out policies to resist
inappropriate development of residential
Gardens
which I think is what Chris mentioned
when he said about if anybody's got
quite a decent gun they can't just go
and put a house in there
for example where development will cause
harm to the local area now
this this is a bit difficult in some
respects
because I would say you could argue it's
a windfall site
that can be developed sorry um do
windfall sites have to be within a
development boundary yeah so the
windfall sites are allocated generally
but um or they are allocated but they're
not got a specific policy so they'll be
within the development boundary for
example you might have a little bit of
land in weekly but it wouldn't be when
that winkly window to allocation
um that could come forward and that is
classified as a windfall so you couldn't
classify this as a windfall because it's
outside the development boundary you'd
have to give the local plan privacy in
that regard right I think that our
captain to one more point then yes I
just wonder if you've got any cover on
St 1919a which is affordable housing on
exception sites and starter homes
exception sites yeah so we did um
in effect it can't be an exception site
because it's adjacent to hold so a bit
weird I know but policy is quite
specific in that it only enables
exception sites via
rural settlements Etc
um so you can't allow that on that basis
because what what it is and
um
as far as our policy team is concerned
they've already got adequate housing in
whole survey significant numbers
um over and above really what is
necessary or needed and then on top of
that you've got the affordable housing
delivered so what they're saying is that
you don't need the exception sites in
this location an exception site should
be delivered in the smaller areas
um not the main centers of a or census
in that regard and again it's not
technically exceptional because the
it's not affordable housing by
definition it's set out in the uh
in the policy and the supplementary
planning documents and and usually an
exception site they have to deliver as
much as possible for it to be viables
it's not just the case of saying we'll
give you 30 they need to prove why 50 it
isn't viable so there's a bit more work
which would need to go
applications refused as per the
officer's report is there a second to
please
well regrettably I will secondly because
I cannot find the ground to
uh my heart wants to go the other way
but
right so it has been proposed by cancer
I'm seconded by Council dependent and
that the application is refused so we
will now go to the vote please thank you
chair councilor Christie
councilor Haynes or councilor Harper
councilor leather or councilor lock for
all councilor Pennington core councilor
Smith or councilor Wheatley or councilor
Whitaker
so that application is refused thank you
very much indeed
right that is the end of the
applications
so um item number eight appeal decisions
Pages 95 to 105.
any comments
either number nine cost on appeals there
are none
item number 10 the dedicated
agmb applications
any comments on that
um item number 11 the planning decisions
Pages 107 so I go through the page or a
page
foreign
[Applause]
107.
109.
so buy it well no should I mention it or
not
oh I will
feed it on
um yeah 109 it is the
um
halfway down the page it wrecks of
workers dwell in the cactus shop at
winkley
so I mean I drive past this site several
times you might see a couple of llamas
in the little field and you might see
one little polytunnel
and the capture shop advertise and I
thought why on Earth would they want an
agriculture workers to enter so I went
on the plan in Portal and had a look at
everything and I read that it was on an
access Stone
and that little place at winkley just
remembers interest you might be
interested or not is the second largest
commercial Cactus Nursery in the UK
and it is the third largest in Europe
and it grows over 300 000 different
sorts of cacti all done on little winky
error though so I just thought that was
putting the application it perspective
[Laughter]
110.
113.
and refusals 116
and 117.
right so thank you for your attention I
think we've had a long and thorough
discussion and the median is closed at
11 50. thank you very